[Music]
i can't stop watching the video
i watch the video almost over and over
not every day but every now and then i
just think about it
this city's depressed it's full of
depression no one knows what's happening
no one knows what the actual
restrictions mean
people are confused people are
down-hearted it's just so sad
he is a weak person who
feels the need to portray himself as
strong he's willing to sacrifice
anybody on the altar of that endeavor
the beauty of competition is to accept
that from one day to the next somebody
can be better than you
and challenge you and if that doesn't
happen anymore it's
not it's not sport anymore it's your
business
[Music]
welcome back the health secretary has
defended england's new three-tier
lockdown system
following claims that ministers ignored
advisers and in the last half hour the
labour leader sakir stama
called instead for a two to three week
circuit breaker which amounts in essence
to
a short sharp national lockdown let's go
to liverpool our correspondent tom
parmenter is there
a place that city to be placed under the
strictest of the new rules coming in
tomorrow tom is liverpool prepared
for the stricter measures coming into
force
well it doesn't have much choice that is
what is happening we're at the sandon
pub tonight one of the big football pubs
in anfield
a pub that on a match day would expect
to take 80 000 pounds on the bar alone
and they're preparing to shut the doors
tonight just a few days away from the
merseyside derby
this weekend let's bring in kate stewart
who's the landlady here
this is a tough tough night for you
you're already down in the cellar
looking at the stock that you've got
left
selling off cheap so i've just been down
in the cellar and checking the dates and
i'm saying
just get rid of it i've already been
stung on the last lockdown
for 40 000 pounds worth of stuff that's
not happening again
even if i have to stand outside and give
it away that stock's going
this is one of the biggest football pubs
in the country isn't it you can
accommodate 6 000 people on
your premises here and you take 80 000
pounds on a match day
this is crushing for you it's crushing
to everything about
what's happened here we've gone from
being world renowned
world famous people flying in just to
watch the football here
to take in 300 pounds in a day and then
the government to offer a meter short at
750 pounds a week
believe me that doesn't touch the sides
to open the doors of here it's costing
me 34 000 pounds a month
that's before we even opened they're
just my normal bills yet we take big
takens but we also have big bills to go
with it
and how would you describe how the city
region is feeling tonight
this city's depressed it's full of
depression no one knows what's happening
no one knows what the actual
restrictions mean
people are confused people are
down-hearted it's just so sad that
people have come in here coming here
every single day for the drink
and this is what they do this this is
their life the people behind the bar
this is their livelihood no one's
thought about that no one thought about
the implications of people's mental
health
it'll have so people will be sitting in
the house on their own or drinking in
the house where there's no regulations
where's this going to go it is
a new situation without an end point
what do you think will be the effect of
closing the bars and pubs
on merseyside i don't think this is
going to have any effect whatsoever
they're going to close the pubs again
they're going to reopen them everyone's
going to want to search out get out
there again the r8 is going to go up
again
none of it's making sense none of it's
working and it's an absolute joke to be
honest
tonight we have an exclusive interview
with george floyd's son quincy
who says he can't stop watching the
video if his father's final minutes
those eight minutes and 46 seconds under
the knee
of a white police officer in minneapolis
in may this year
in a special report as part of our
coverage of black history month
we brought quincy together with neville
lawrence whose son stephen was murdered
in a racist attack
in london in april 1993.
sky's not phillips has this exclusive
interview
i can't stop watching the video i watch
this video almost over and over
not every day but every now and then i
just think about it
it's a sort of grief neville lawrence
knows all too well
we've brought the two men together for
the first time
when i saw the incident with your dad
being kneeling on the floor with that
man
kneeling on his neck and the other
officers around
standing and watching tears came out my
eyes
like george floyd stephen lawrence's
racist killing
27 years ago has left an indelible mark
in british society how did you get
through
the tragedy of having what happened to
your son um
we had to go into counseling
the old family had to go into counseling
and and talk about it
even now really right now you know if i
went
to if i went to a funeral
to see somebody being buried i can't go
near
when they're putting the per the the
coffin down i can't go near it
because i'm looking i'm thinking that
i'm re-burying stephen again
i remember watching your dad's funeral
on tv and seeing just how emotional
and just how raw it was for your family
can you describe what it was like for
you
it's like you see them breathing
my knees just kind of buckle
i kiss him in the forehead let him know
that everything's gonna be all right
your son is gonna be here with
your family's here with you you're not
gonna go out and bang
and we were to go bury him
what is it like for you when you hear
those words i can't breathe
the knee on his neck said he couldn't
breathe
just thinking about what he was saying
it's not going to be very easy
and and for all the years that i've been
struggling it hasn't been easy but
you have to have um a ham in view
and the aim in view of my family was to
try and get justice
it took us a long time but eventually we
got some justice
and you can't give up you know you gotta
keep fighting
in 2012 two men were finally jailed for
life
for the racist murder of neville's son
i have a hard time twisting any cops
right about now
i'm not saying all kinds of bad cops
are not good
but have to my father demonstrated me
did not press anytime
donald trump defied opinion even within
his own family earlier today
i spoke to his niece mary who told me
his
weak character as she defines it has put
millions of americans in danger she's
written a book
about her uncle and i started by asking
her given the divisions it's causing
within the family
why she did it i wanted the american
voter to have as much information as
possible going into the 2020 election
which they clearly didn't have going
into 2016
and i think i i hoped anyway that that
coupled with the evidence of his
increasingly cruel bizarre behavior
uh would help make the case uh more
effectively
it would be a sad commentary on me if i
had been hanging on to any bitterness
the book was
i wrote the book primarily as an
american citizen not so much as his
niece and certainly not somebody who was
uh looking for revenge
well you're uh now a trained
psychologist or a qualified
psychologist as a clinician
say you were someone outside how would
you
analyze donald trump as a patient
you know i don't think we need
necessarily to know what happened to him
at two and a half
to realize that this is somebody who
has serious um psychological disorders
that have never been treated
and continue to worsen over time i think
his behavior and his comments
just lay bare uh the the essential
nature of this
this man he is a weak person
who feels the need to portray himself as
strong
he's willing to sacrifice anybody on the
altar of that endeavor
um by saying the things he's been saying
he has put in danger millions more
americans
by telling them to go out and not be
afraid of something that can
kill you and is killing people every day
the villagers a place locals call
disneyland for the elderly
once reliable elderly voters
turning out for his rival
this is trump territory you know we have
600
700 golf cart parades for trump
and then two weeks later a hundred show
up for biden
and they're doing riding with biden
because they can't do the trump train
down the road though a very different
tune
who's gonna vote for joe biden
one two three four five six and how many
for trump
oh so biden has it you wear your heart
on your golf cart here and sometimes
at a cost you get yelled at you get
cussed out
why can't you see yourself voting for
trump
i just don't like the man i don't trust
him he's a bigot he's a bully
and i don't like bullies
now life often imitates art but what
happens when it's the other way round
that's what actor tim robbins best known
for his role in the shawshank redemption
found when he sat down to pen his latest
satire
about u.s politics and the trump white
house written
18 months ago and originally intended as
a film
the piece of work ended up becoming a
podcast my colleague dermot monahan
spoke to tim robbins about
bobo supreme i had to just adjust and i
wanted to tell the story
uh now and so i started thinking about
what a
film would be for the ears how do you
how do you make a
soundscape uh to to fill in
uh listeners imagination it's
effectively an imagining of um
what life with president trump because
that is he president trump in the white
house
it could be pouring rain on your
supporters i'm not sure that's a good
optic
they're coming we paid them to come make
sure they don't leave i'm making a
speech when the polls close
that lawn better be packed with
barbellists here's the thing i
when you do satire it's not a literal
representation of what's going on you
have to
use your imagination to fill in what the
what the
gaps might be the imagine what it is
like to be
inside a room where there's no cameras
rolling and there's no one to witness
the behavior
i just started trying to tap into what
the
id of the character is what what the um
what the
psyche that uh what the dream life is
like it starts with a dream and it ends
with a dream and during bible supreme
we're not really sure whether we're
dreaming
this or whether it's his nightmare or
our nightmare
with the trump presidency well you know
some of it seems pretty surreal
certainly if you'd describe
what might be happening four or five
years ago people would say nah nah nah
that that can't be happening and you
know we look at um the
the post covid experience it was a gift
from god
it's a miracle he feels 20 years younger
he's now immune
you know how do you how do you satirize
that
well um i don't know you have him rip
off his shirt and there's a superman
shirt underneath it i don't know uh yes
you're right it's like how do you
satirize satire he is uh very good at
uh keeping on message and
not accepting responsibility for
anything he's ever
done wrong i think he's lived his entire
life that way and
we're seeing the ramification
ramifications of that when a person like
that
is the leader of the free world tell me
about the
prospect the possibility of life
imitating arts for you personally you've
mentioned bob roberts that
film from what i think is 28 years ago
now when you played
a candidate and you know what i'm going
to ask is there ever any chance do you
have any desire to to stand yourself to
get involved in electoral
politics and you can't get away with
saying you're uh
you're too old for that now look at the
candidates now
um no it's uh i i really prefer being a
satirist
i don't think there's ever been a
politician satirist has there
the former arsenal manager arsene wenger
has criticized the plans of some clubs
in the premier league to overhaul the
competition giving themselves a greater
slice of the revenue and even prompting
suggestions
of uh some sort of breakaway super
league the plans were voted down
yesterday but some clubs still believe
change is necessary wenger whose
autobiography my life
in red and white was published this week
also told me
that the connection between the biggest
clubs and
the smaller teams was vital
at the moment the interest of the
premier league is not to create a
european super league
it's more the threat made by the other
countries who want
to stop the domination of the english
premier league to create a super league
so the interest of england
is to a little bit fight against that
because that would
go against their own interest do you
want to see
the kind of pyramid system with
promotion
and relegation where small clubs can get
into the premier league they can dream
about being in the premier league
is that a good thing and can that
survive
of course as long as it's like you asked
me basically
is the sporting merit still
good that's the basis of our sport it's
competition
and to accept the beauty of competition
is to accept that from one day to the
next somebody can be better than you
and challenge you and if that doesn't
happen anymore it's not
it's not sport anymore it's your
business in the 22 years
i played against every club in the
championship they were all at some stage
in the premier league
so the dream uh comes through and that
is uh
the essence of our sport was obviously
very competitive
competitive with the other big clubs
competitive with the managers
the relationship with alex ferguson and
jose mourinho
seem to border on hatred at you know
something yes it is it is uh like that
when you're in competition because
basically it's uh
it's you or me if we compete together
you know so
you need a certain aggression level you
need a certain
desire to get the other out and
sometimes it gets out of control and
when i
i lost sometimes a few times only
because i managed 1235 games but a few
times yes i got
i lost my control and you shouldn't
black lives matter is a big part of
sport generally
this year do you think black managers
are discriminated against in football
honestly i don't know
i don't i personally i
you don't in sport i think can be a huge
example for the society because you
don't look at the color of the skin you
look how good you are
sport is based on merit and in the
football team
doesn't matter what color you are if
you're good you play you know and that's
why football can be a great example
would you like to see more of course but
if i'm black tomorrow
i do not want to be employed because i'm
black i want to employ because i'm good
just on covid um do you think
fans should be back in grounds at the
moment some fans at least
you think you know a few guys
honestly i would love fans to come back
to the ground
and at the moment what you have always
life is always about priorities
priorities is first
medical health and secure safety of
people so
we have to to accept but at the moment
that is not possible
the world watched them grow up and now
it seems grow apart
a new book about the inner workings of
the royal family
is set to shine a light on claims of a
rift between princes william
and harry among the insights in battle
of brothers
is the claim that the queen viewed
prince harry and meghan markle as
erratic
and impulsive in the lead-up to their
exit from
royal life its author royal biographer
robert lacy
joins me now hello to robert great to
see you
at this feud between the two brothers
how real and how deep does it go
i think it goes pretty deep and it goes
actually back to the years when you were
a royal correspondent but
we didn't know then that um the patterns
that um
we now see were developing then
inevitably harry
had to play the the role of the spare to
the air
and it was turned things around though
hadn't he robert
in terms of his reputation he was hugely
well regarded for his military career
the work that he'd done uh with veterans
for example
and when he met and married meghan
markle there was a real hope that this
young couple could help the future of
the monarchy and modernizing
them and yet and yet it all went wrong
well let's hope he's not all gone wrong
let us hope that um
i think there are signs um that they
remain close they speak on the phone
um i think next year will be the the you
know the year of challenge
did she megan underestimate the power of
the institution that it wasn't willing
to bend and and on the other hand
did it underestimate her that she wasn't
willing to to be forced to fit into its
conventions
you you've got it you've obviously
stubbed studied the subject sarah
because i i i it is both sides so
so many people take one side or the
other say it's megan was entirely
to blame um but as you say um
i i think with hindsight it's clear that
the palace when they saw
this um self-made successful woman a
celebrity in her own right before she
met harry a millionaires in her own
right before
she met harry um
she was some unlike any anyone had been
before
in in the royal family she has these
dedicated
um beliefs uh feminism social change
there is there is the cutting edge um
her
her dedication to these causes of course
has clashed with
the royal tradition of uh impartiality
and um that's going to be one of the
challenges that's going to have to be
sorted out in the future
if the couple are going to come back in
some way into the family
just wanted to bring you the olympic
champion armed forces veteran and
honorary colonel dame kelly holmes she's
supporting an initiative to help
veterans with access
to training work opportunities and to
connect with loved ones through
a new veterans rail card captain tom
moore will be one of the first to
receive one we're lucky to say that dame
kelly is with us now hello to you
hi hi how you doing tell us a bit more
about it
yep so a new veterans rail card i'm
pleased to
show you my there we go very honored um
basically yeah it's been launched today
it gives veterans
one-third off of well fair along with a
companion
and up to four children sixty percent
off
that's amazing captain tom's gonna get
one i believe is that right
yes apparently he's got his now so i'm
going to say he's got the first one he's
been our hero
during lockdown so i'll just say i've
got the second one i think that's the
best way to say it
so many people have given me years of
their lives
and their efforts to something special
and now to get this card really is the
icing on the cake
the government wants to make the uh the
uk the best place
in the world to be a veteran what needs
to change for that to happen do you
think kelly
well i think firstly you know initiative
like this it just gives
a veteran something they feel connected
back with
you know this uh basically card and
design has got the
navy army and the air force colours
and you know i was very proud to serve
now a lot of
service personnel have obviously
sacrificed um doing their service
and i think what we need to do as a
country is to recognize
the power and the actual skill set that
veterans have
i think maybe if we did that we'll have
a lot better places
out there in the workplace with really
committed
disciplined respectful citizens
[Music]
you